[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
was there was there news yesterday
[Music]
oh
did you see the judge Rick Roll the
media
that was hilarious
they're like yeah you can have the
cameras in the courtroom sure come on in
you can have the cameras in the
courtroom
and then he's like was that good enough
were you
did that satisfy you enough
did you watch that part
that's hilarious totally [__] Rick
rolled them
uh the drama last night
leading up to
the clerk
handing over the 100 or no yeah it's
almost 100 it's like 98 pages I think
it's how many it is 98 pages
is that including the cover page or is
that
beyond the cover page so that makes it
99 technically so we might as well be at
a hundred
page indictment yesterday 19 defendants
19.
and
30 30
unindicted co-conspirators 49
[__]
49 co-conspirators all together well 48
including uh Grandpa
and they're surprised that there's Rico
charges in Georgia against these
[__]
funny Willis popular
for her for her Rico and uh trials and
indictments she's she's apparently doing
a RICO and our trial right now she's
famous for the uh the Atlanta teachers
Rico charges
that's one reason why she became the D.A
because she made her made her name on
the teachers uh Rico where they were
they were they were [__] around with
test scores
in the Atlantic Atlanta School District
a lot of people are pissed off about
that
there's a lot of people pissed this
morning about this indictment but it's
all marketeers
so I'll swim in marketeers today no
problem
listen okay
let's let's back up a bit let's let's go
back
let's go back
let's let's rewind
a bit
and let's go to the time when Donald
Trump decided that he was gonna run
again in 2024.
right
and the reason why Donald Trump is
[__] his britches this morning and
he's gonna have some kind of [__]
Mike Lindell cyber shinposium or I don't
know if they're gonna like change each
other's diapers or something I have no
idea what they're gonna do how they're
gonna prove
that Trump
is innocent
but let's go back to when he announced
he was running for president because we
all we all know why he's running for
president he doesn't actually want to be
president he doesn't actually
think he can be a president because he's
not he's he he pretended the four years
he was President he did a shitty job at
pretending
the reason why the reason why Donald
Trump is running
and he started his run directly after
the 2022 midterms is because he wanted
to start the cycle
and he wanted to start the cycle so he
could guarantee he would be the
Republican nominee
and the reason why is because people
were telling him you're going to be in a
criminal courtroom
in 2024
and possibly your only way out of it is
to have a really good excuse to have a
way out of it and one of those excuses
could be to be the Republican nominee
so your best chance is to go ahead and
cinch it up now
you're the cult leader they're a cult
they're going to follow you into the
into the Kool-Aid Lake here
oh they're definitely going to drink the
Kool-Aid
so he decided to run early
oh no he won't be able to win
Ron DeSantis oh he'll come out of
nowhere he's so popular in Florida
oh right to santis
Rhonda Santos if you believe polls again
I don't believe Bulls I think they're
[__]
but if you believe the polls that are
out there Ron DeSantis isn't like single
digits now
and you don't have to look at a poll to
know that Rhonda Santos is very very
very [__] unpopular because he's
[__] weird
sorry I mean Chris Christie's a pulling
ahead of him some of these pulls
Jesus Christ Maga hates that
[__] and he's pulling more than
DeSantis
I don't know again I think polls are
[__]
I don't know if I believe that in in the
slightest but I do know this I do know
this I do know how Cults work
and having knowing those little sets of
facts
only only leads me to believe that what
I have been saying all along is going to
come true he is going to be the nominee
and I'm telling you that is going to
afford him the ability
to fend off trials in 2024. oh but Tony
there's seven trials and Bonnie Willis
said she's gonna get it done in six
months again I keep telling you stop
she she's trying to scare the defendants
into a plea deal
here
I mean think about it if you just got if
you just got [__] caught a a felony
case a RICO felony case in Fulton County
Georgia and she's like look [__] I've
got an arrest warrant for you and you
better show up by next Friday and I'm
gonna [__] try you within six months
and if it's Bonnie Willis I'm telling
you I don't know if you watched the
press conference last night but she's a
John Wayne toilet paper [__]
she's rough tough and don't take [__]
off nobody she don't give a [__] who you
are
she don't care
she's gonna get your dumb ass
and I'm telling you I'm telling you what
she's trying to do with this I'm gonna
go to try on six months because listen
they're not gonna go to trial in six
months I wish they would I think Georgia
probably has the the best opportunity to
get there possibly but man after seeing
the indictment last night I don't know
there's 19 defendants there's 41 charges
you're gonna have 19 different councils
think about the jury selection that
you're gonna have to go through there's
gonna be 19 councils selecting jury they
got a RICO case right now herrico case
right now is their jury selection has
been nine months alone
so I get I get the uh everyone wanting
ah we want to get to trial because
really Georgia is the place that the
cameras will be
and and honestly it's gonna make these
Trump and his allies and his criminal
cartel here
looked like a bunch of impotent fools is
what it'll make them appear to be I mean
these aren't [__] gang members tap
face tattoos and [__] muscles look like
they've been on the yard for four
[__] years straight no
Sydney Powell
Jeffrey Clark you remember Jeffrey Clark
[__] in his underwear in his
front yard
that guy come on man
these aren't intimidating people
they're gonna look like feeble little
shits in court especially in a Georgia
Court especially when Bonnie Willis is
standing there
and she takes the microphone
they're gonna look like dumb [__] that
they truly are she [__] ran off one
side and down the other of them
yesterday with a goddamn chair
how I put it in the title they she
chaired him yesterday
God damn she got more hits yesterday
than at the Alabama boat brawl
but don't get too excited about having a
televised trial before the election
there's going to be a lot of televised
hearings but it's going to be like
yesterday that's what I keep telling you
about this this idea that [__] this
thing is reality TV you're gonna have to
get over that because yesterday and I
told the judge rick rolled the media
totally [__] with them
they were like yeah we want we want
cameras he's like all right you can have
cameras he didn't read a single [__]
word off that indictment he just looked
at it like oh my [__] god did you see
the look on his face when he was like
Jesus 19 defendants
41 charges Rico oh [__] me
that was it
just look on his face that's all we got
right
he didn't sit there and read all 98
Pages he didn't read the the cover page
he didn't read who was on the indictment
or what the charges were and he could
have done all that but he didn't
which is only a sign that that judge who
is assigned to this case is probably not
going to make a total [__] circus out
of this he's going to allow cameras in
the courtroom
but he's not going to make a circus out
of this so if that's what you're
expecting I I think I think your
expectations are going to be broken
but there is one expectation that is not
broken yesterday and that's this is
[__] serious
I've been telling you I've been waiting
to see two questions What charges and
how many [__] there are 49
co-conspirators in this indictment
in this conspiracy of Rico to overturn
the election in Georgia and not just
Georgia also hey hey remember remember
when Tony said Arizona Wisconsin
Michigan and Pennsylvania yeah there
those states are in there too
and this basically lays out a road map
for those states to charge maybe as well
depends on the laws in those States
Georgia obviously has a very strong RICO
law
and that in the Fulton County D.A Willis
is willing to strike and Hammer the son
of a [__]
think about that 19 charge defendants on
41 charges 41 counts right
our 41 total charges through those 19.
and
and there's 30 unindicted
co-conspirators
and everyone's standing around going
what took so long are you [__] me
what took so long there was 49 people
involved in this conspiracy 49
[__] think about think about
all the [__] communication all the
emails all the phone calls all the
testimony
that's just that's not Witnesses that's
just the conspirators just the people
who were [__] committing the crime
another significant point of this
indictment is not only that Donald Trump
is the head of the of of the RICO
operation here Mark Meadow is charged a
lot of people questioning that like whoa
I thought Mark Meadows making deals yeah
Mark Meadows seems to be uh I I think
he's got the attitude that this is that
even this RICO case is going to end up
in federal court that's probably what
Mark Meadow's attorney is doing this
morning is trying to get a motion to get
this in federal court not in State Court
and the reason why is because Mark
Meadows seems to have a deal with the
feds
and that's where Mark Meadows and his
Council would love to have his charges
with the feds not with Georgia
and the reason why is because he seems
to have a deal against Trump
rather with Jack Smith or who knows that
the doj it appears to be Jack Smith and
the special counsel as who he has a deal
with
another significant uh character
is Grandpa farty mcsharty Rudy Giuliani
and his Fart Catcher Jenna Ellis
oh Jenny you dumbass oh you dumb [__]
[__] listen Jenna Ellis was in a
goddamn Twitter space with me and Gabe
and Gabe asked her questions over and
over and over again and she wouldn't
answer and then she ran away out of the
Twitter space
and the reason why is because what I
said yesterday she's a coward
why do you think she's supporting Ronda
Santa she don't want to be appear to be
in Trump's Universe right now and the
reason why is because she knew this
indictment was coming she knew she
committed crime
she knew it
Rudy knew it
speaking of Rudy Giuliani you know I had
to howl on Hal Sparks on as last week or
the week before I don't know that runs
away from me she's been so many
indictments ago right
[Music]
ah Hal Sparks was on and we said you
know America's mayor is going to be a
derogatory statement right you get some
drunk walking in the bar grabbing women
oh you got big kitties those are my
titties yeah I want to overturn
elections you're gonna be like well
there's America's mayor right there
it's going to be derogatory
but Rudy Giuliani I don't know if you
know this he's famous for being the
United States Attorney of the southern
district of New York bringing down
Mobsters on uh what was that called oh
yeah Rico charges
and here he is catching a case in Fulton
County Georgia
because he learned Too Much from the
criminals that he used to prosecute I
guess
I don't know maybe he thought that he
was better at it than they are hey [__]
I don't know
I I mean it seems to be that Trump has
[__] over a lot of these [__]
including Rudy Giuliani and Lady G oh my
God Lindsey Graham on Fox news last
night
just losing her [__] oh my God she was
pissed did you see that
Lindsay was [__] pissed she was going
off
I don't know maybe maybe Trump does have
a lot of dirt on on some of these on
some of these uh these Trump [__] like
like Lindsey Graham lady G and Grandpa
farty mcsharty Rudy colludi Giuliani
right I don't know I would say he
probably does he's known Rudy for a long
time surely he's got plenty of dirt on
Rudy
not to mention the dirt about the hunter
Biden laptop that Trump probably has on
Rudy because he had him commit federal
crimes doing that
the other thing too is
Trump still Trump still owes Rudy
Giuliani legal fees for the crimes that
he committed in these Rico charges
hahaha
are you [__] me oh man
Trump paying everybody's legal bills but
his own right
oh man he's like give me money I'm a
billionaire and I need money to pay
legal fees besides the lawyers that I
hire everyone else's lawyers they'll all
pay those lawyers
so what do you think this looks like
that's what I want to know is what do
these surrenders look like right because
we're gonna get we're gonna get a camera
a camera in each one of these
arraignments
that's what I think is going to be
significant here that's what that's what
I think could be a game changer if you
want to talk about cameras in a
courtroom
is these arraignments now the only way
that these arraignments work and I mean
moving the needle on the political
spectrum is that if these [__]
feel cold steel against their wrist
that's right if they're handcuffed into
the courtroom and I think the sheriff
has said hey I'm treating you just like
any other defendant now maybe we could
go back and look and see if there's any
images of the gang members that are in
the Ricoh case right now that Bonnie
Willis is charging and see during their
arraignments if they were under
handcuffs
when they were arraigned if they were
well you know maybe maybe just maybe
maybe maybe we can get images of of
these [__] Political Criminals these
political Rico criminals
this treasonous crime syndicate
maybe we can get images of them in
handcuffs I don't know maybe
isn't that what you want isn't that what
you want to see Donald Trump with his
hands behind his back
cuffed
deflated
demoralized he can't say a word in open
court oh my god he has to remain silent
in open court
that judge ain't gonna put up with that
[__] him yelling and screaming
talking his [__] lunacy no [__]
way
wouldn't put up with that [__] for a
minute now bats now that's qual that's
quality content right there
will we get it I don't know
I I don't know
I have no idea if we're gonna get those
images it seems that we're gonna have
cameras in the arraignment because the
the Press wants the cameras in there and
this judge does not seem shy to having
media inside the courtroom with their
cameras on and the lights on with the
microphones
now how good a quality it will be I mean
you know that's gonna be to be
determined
but we'll see
but there's 19 defendants that have to
turn themselves in by next Friday how
many of us how many of them do you think
for spawning Willis to go get him oh my
God I I almost bet Cindy Bell I almost
bet
Sydney Bell refuses to go to Fulton
County before next Friday and she's like
come and get me [__] with her Dr Pepper
her diet Dr Pepper
you think that's what she does she goes
gets like 12 cases of diet Dr Pepper
finds a bunker somewhere it's like come
and get me [__]
I actually want to see some of these
people as fugitives on the run I'm not
gonna lie we're gonna do this reality TV
show thing hey let's [__] do this
[__] let's make a movie out of this why
not that's what everyone wants right
that's that's what everyone out in the
world wants they want this to be a big
reality TV show everyone's calling for
cameras in the courtroom and all kinds
of crazy [__] that isn't gonna happen oh
yeah Bonnie Willis is gonna go to trial
next week
that's that's what everyone's saying
it's so funny the media yesterday oh my
God they're on pins and needles they
were ready man they had their [__]
cameras Oh yeah and then Rick Rolled
by the judge nothing better I laughed my
ass off that was actually funnier than
some of the charges
some of the other significant charges
and some of the other significant uh
storyline here is that funny Willis did
not allow these scumbag [__] to
intimidate the election the election
volunteers the election workers
Ruby Freeman and her daughter Shea Moss
they did not get away with that and it
doesn't seem that they're going to it
looks like someone's going to be held
accountable for destroying those those
women's lives
we saw their story at the January 6th
select committee hearings
and now it just may seem that someone's
going to be held accountable in Fulton
County
the the publicist for Kanye West is that
right
you remember this video we showed this
video where she's like
trying to get them to say they cheated
or some [__] or I don't remember right
they're charged
it's [__] crazy
and some of these names of people of low
Lane low-lying campaign uh workers that
you don't know
Apparently one of Sydney Powell's
underlings is also in the in the list
of indictees
but what I want to know the question
that I want to know
is who in the [__] is these 30
unindicted co-conspirators that's the
list I want right
that's the list I want
I mean one is pointed out in this
indictment clearly
that they drafted a letter before the
election even happened that Trump was
going to declare Victory no matter what
laying out the groundwork for the big
lie
laying out the groundwork to defraud his
supporters into giving him money
to fight the election or whatever the
hell it was that he didn't use the money
for
maybe used it maybe use that money to to
play a musical classified documents with
the boxes I don't know maybe
who knows
but who are now the question is who are
the 30
unindicted co-conspirators that's what
we want to know
because we want the story
but don't expect to have the story
anytime soon
I know Bonnie Willis said last night
that her goal is to get to trial within
six months but again 19 defendants
that's 19 councils that get to have
something to do at the jury pool this is
gonna take for [__] ever
the other thing too is this judge
doesn't seem like he he's gonna rush to
this
he's not gonna play the the the public
sentiment game
just like he clearly clearly was sending
the signal to the media hey you don't
control the courtroom I do
that's clearly the message he was
sending to them last night
I'll show you a few clips of what he
said because he's basically like well
did that make you come
how was that
did that sexually satisfy you
not in so many words he was joking he
was playing with him he's just playing
with him you know what I mean and then
he's like get the [__] out of my
courtroom like literally he's like get
the [__] out of here you gotta leave get
the hell out of here
he's like not a mean way but in a mean
way get the hell out of here
so he's clearly sending a signal to the
media that he controls the courtroom not
them
that that he is the circus master
they they are just the clowns and he
controls
the circus
so we'll see how this plays out but
again again don't get too excited but
it's gonna be it's gonna be a nice week
it I mean it's only [__] Tuesday
it's only Tuesday
at this point and they got till next
Friday to turn themselves in and we got
a great press conference on Monday where
Donald Trump's gonna [__] the bed again
he's gonna tell us why he's a lunatic
and everyone's like oh my God the
network shouldn't cover it [__] we
should cut in we should cut in on
national TV to let this idiot [__]
dig his grave do you think Donald Trump
is gonna say anything but only what will
hurt him in a general election
you think he's gonna look sane
do you think he's gonna look like an
adult do you think he's going to look
like a reasonable person in this
whatever the hell it is this press
conference at Bedminster
he's gonna look like a crazed lunatic
televised that that's the thing you want
to televise [__] show the entire country
force him to sit down and watch this
crazy ass [__] say crazy ass
[__] they'll be oh and I'm sure everyone
in the country would be like oh yeah I
want to vote for him after what he says
what the hell is he gonna say Mike
Lindell is doing a cyber Symposium in
Springfield Missouri and he has a report
that I have in my hand
he's gonna [__] the bed
Mike you know everyone's like how did it
take Bonnie Willis two and a half years
to finally indict this idiot and these
these morons these treasonous pieces of
[__] how did it take so long
well why hasn't take why has it taken
Mike Lindell so long to give us the
evidence of how Donald Trump won I mean
God damn it's been two and a half years
Mike you spent how many billions of
dollars you said
and you haven't come up you haven't come
up with a good excuse of why you guys
wanted to steal the election yet
come on man and you're worried about
Trump this being televised hell this is
the thing that needs to be televised I
actually think Donald Trump should do a
press conference on this issue in
particular
every single day three times a day and
we should televise it on every channel
every [__] one of them
if you want this [__] to be
unpopular let him talk do you remember
what happened in 2020
do you remember this there was a there
was what was it what what what was that
pandemic called oh yeah covet that's
right that's right
we had a pandemic and that [__]
was getting out in front of the
microphone saying crazy [__] every
goddamn day of the week
and his number's plummeted and his
popularity plummeted and he got his
[__] ass Smoked by sleepy Joe who was
hiding in a basement by eight million
votes
and you and you think this guy
televising a press conference is going
to help him hails to the no it's gonna
hurt him he's begging us to to [__]
broadcast those crazy videos that he
does right now on his on his true Social
account his fraud social videos
[__] broadcast those
but he's still not going to lose the
primary I know I know I know
everyone wants someone else to get in
the race or win or whatever again you're
not understanding our Cults work and the
media is finally starting to come around
to this I tell you last night I was
listening to the media and this morning
I was listening to the media their
commentary on this they've really come
around to the Tony Michael's idea that
yes he is going to win there's no one
that can stand in his way
and even if the Republicans don't like
it he's still gonna be their guy
they don't have a choice here they made
this [__] bed they could haven't they
could have impeached him in 14th him and
they didn't and that is the moment that
is the moment that Donald Trump remained
the nominee and the front runner in that
moment when he tried to overturn the
government and they said you know what
that's not such a big deal
that's not such a big deal we can live
with that
well you're living with it [__]
and we're gonna expose it every single
day of the week right here on the Tony
Michaels podcast two full hours
two
full hours every single weekday and it's
Tuesday Tuesday taco Tuesday Texas Paul
Tuesday it's August 15th
the day after the indictment and boy are
we going to have a fun show for you
today uh go ahead and hit the Subscribe
button you're not going to want to miss
a single thing today tomorrow the next
day so hit the Subscribe button down
below make sure to hit the thumbs up and
hey if you don't like me uh [__] you too
hit the thumbs down and get in the
comments tell me why you don't like me
and if you want to if you want to do a
venmo chat you know we don't have we
don't have Super Chat because YouTube
hates my guts but we got venmo chat now
just go to the venmo chat the Link's
down in the description below
but you can see me on Vendo at the Tony
Michaels and we had a couple yesterday
and on Friday so if you want to get them
get him up on the screen give me a Super
Chat and I'll give you a shout out here
on the show and also visit patreon.com
Tony Michaels we're going to be doing
some Round Table of democracy work this
week so don't miss that
don't go anywhere we got Texas Paul when
we come right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show we got a couple
birthdays in the chat
right got a couple birthday feelings
skinny Jupiter happy birthday in Sage
Ohio happy birthday to both of you happy
birthday to you
listen a lot of people worried about my
eye I don't know maybe it was my blood
pressure yesterday or something I don't
know I put drops in it just before the
show that's probably why it got really
red I don't know what the [__] to tell
you what do you want you want me to wear
a patch
like Elmer Fudd I mean Elmer Rhodes huh
matey I don't I don't know what to tell
you it's red
it's all right it doesn't hurt
it does it's not painful it's not
burning
I don't know maybe maybe it was that
person that sat on my face it could be
I don't know what the [__] it is hell
what am I supposed to do how am I
supposed to do I put drops in it it
doesn't hurt
it's good and and someone says broken
blood vessel that could be what it is
but I put drops in it just in case just
in case you know that weird stuff I was
doing over the weekend I got
conjunctivitis
you know what I'm talking about you know
the butt pedal eye stuff Hell Boy ah
we're off to a good start with Texas
Paul it's Tuesday Texas poem welcome to
the show my friend
um glad to be here man your eyes are red
for the same reason my eyes are red
don't lie don't deny it
oh man let me tell you something
um of course
I said last week that I thought we would
get indictments on Monday
um I was correct Monday now it was late
Monday they all stayed the clerk stayed
the judge stayed the judge like hey go
get dinner we're gonna indict this
[__] tonight
and the one reason why is because they
had the security already they already
had it set up it really was it really
would have been
um not ideal for them to tear down all
the security or or let loose the
security and then do it today you know
revamp the security have the media come
back and have the circus again but I
thought it was hilarious because it was
live TV when the media thought oh this
judge is going to read this [__] we're
gonna know exactly what it is and he
grabbed those papers and his look in his
eyes he's like holy [__] and he's like
all right see you later
it's totally [__] just just tricked
him into this and I I again I think what
it was
is that the judge was showing the media
that hey this is my circus and I'm the
ring Master you don't get to control
this I do what do you what do you think
what did you think of that last night
when you watched the clerk come in and
and give that the the indictment to the
judge
oh man I tell you what I I just there
was a little thing that happened
yesterday that kind of blew the mood for
me a little bit but
um you know you Tony you know my wife
you know that she has a dark sense of
humor she is she is
special
she walks in I'm out in the garage right
been there all day I'm doing learning
you know I've taken up woodworking man
I'm sitting there on the lathe I'm
turning a new handle this and the other
I'm finally getting in my groove finally
figuring this [__] out she walks up and
hands me this
yeah
the bogus indictments that came out
earlier in the day right right right
right right right right yeah she found
out that they were bogus just that and
the other and she thought it would be
you know she wanted me to come back in
the house and she was playing a joke on
me she hands me this right I take off
she goes back in the house and goes to
the other side of the house where our
bedroom is and and then settles down in
the living room Meanwhile my sweaty
sawdust covered ass still with my face
shield on goes running down the hallway
to my office and I immediately start
posting about the indictments as is my
job
and of course everybody immediately
because I've been out in the garage I
had no idea these were fakes you know
what I mean
and all I hear is laughing coming from
the living room just laughing her ass
off because I'm getting drugged on
social media everybody's like those are
fakes those are fakes
all I hear is laughing from the living
room and then I hear
delete that
and then immediately after that
boom
the real ones hit the real one well you
know yesterday we we we watched um
because the Reuters report happened and
everywhere it was a buzz online so of
course you know it kind of leaked
through the chat and and got into my ear
and uh we actually pulled up those bogus
charges and I was like I don't think
this doesn't seem real right and uh I I
don't know yes again we can't get too
excited about this even this indictment
because I'm gonna be frank with you
yesterday at the press conference with
uh um the D.A fawning Willis I know
again I called her a John Wayne toilet
paper [__] because she really is
rough tough and don't take [__] off
nobody
um but here's the thing here's the thing
is that
she wants she's she's signaling she
wants to go to trial in six months and
again my my suggestion is is this is uh
the D.A Willis trying to pressure people
into turning because she's got 19
defendants here to get to a trial in six
months she's gonna have to have 14 15 16
these son [__] flip and plea out and
get out of this indictment
um so she can try you know a handful of
them four or five of them to get the six
or eight months I mean she's going
through a RICO case right now where
they've been in jury selection for nine
months just the jury selection alone is
nine months now
all this is going to play out on camera
it seems which could be good it could be
bad but that's just the way it's going
to be just like there's not going to be
cameras in the federal courthouse that's
just the way it's going to be but I I
think that people need to prepare
themselves to be disappointed here next
year and what I mean by that is if you
prepare yourself that there's not going
to be a Donald Trump criminal trial next
year and you focus on the issue at hand
that the Republican Party are such
[__] cowards that they're still going
to nominate this [__] criminal
they're still gonna nominate this guy
who wants to overthrow their vote he
does not respect their vote and they're
still going to give it to him when we
focus in on that and we hone in on that
that the Republican party is such a
group of [__] cowards that they will
nominate this piece of sludge then I
think I think we're going to get into a
situation where we can actually get to
the heart of the matter which is use our
ballots to to be Trump's jury right so
tell me because I I know I know you get
a lot of comments out there about some
of your commentary what what are you
hearing what what is the feeling that
people have are people disappointed by
this are they excited by this I mean
what are you seeing on your side of
things if you are
uh that 70 of America that is just you
know you're not in the cult you're not
maggot
you're elated this one is different I
don't know why this feels so differently
I don't know what but everybody is
elated over these indictments I had to
laugh so hard at stuff everything did
you know Tim Poole Baldi locks have you
got his comments today I don't know oh I
I well I was really following Charlie
Kirk last night that little cuck oh my
Tim Poole has declared again that we are
in a civil war yeah oh in the comments
section in the comment section yeah
Tim pool
declared that we're in a civil war for
longer than the Civil War actually
happened right
here's the thing if Stonewall Jackson's
supporters didn't show up at him being
indicted in an Atlanta courthouse by the
opposition party and they didn't show up
I would say that he wasn't in the Civil
War because there was none no Trump
supporters at the courthouse I mean none
and you know what I actually believe
that that probably is a great sign that
hey we can we can get rid of these
[__] idiots it's gonna take a little
bit it's gonna take a process to do this
and really what we need is the American
people to reject trumpism next year in
November and I think that's going to be
the situation that really puts us in a
position to say all right we're done
with trumpism we're [__] done with it
because obviously he's not that popular
or they would at least showed up to in
costume with their stupid [__] Flags
in their weird shirts and hats I mean
something right Gabe Sanchez wouldn't
they have showed up at the Georgia at
the Georgia Courthouse if if really
Trump was this popular what do you think
I think yeah they would have moved your
mic over no no I'm not going to uh
yeah I mean every [__] time with this
guy I think he's he's like he thinks he
can come on a show and not talking to a
microphone or something look I'm just if
I could I'm just throwing my voice okay
I'm just throwing my eyes through it you
know it's for the
effects I got it I got it I see I see so
so back to the the task at hand now that
your microphone's properly placed tell
us did you see the images of all the
Trump supporters that were just
clamoring to support him outside the
Georgia Courthouse not not outside the
courthouse I did see people on Tick Tock
last night oh yeah how that you know
this this was this was the final straw
this was the thing yeah it's people
online are are trying to say that this
you know this
if you look if you listen to any of the
feedback that people
[__]
come on wait final straw like now like
like what what are they what are they
what do they plan on doing on Tic Tac
what are they gonna what is Grandma
gonna make videos from a recliner and
that's how she's gonna it's a civil war
Vietnam
I mean Tim cool Tim pool has been saying
we were in a Civil War for the last four
years and yeah the Civil War went on I
think all right well let me let me let
me pull up ten pool last night let me
see him because I was all over Charlie
Kirk last night because he Charlie Kirk
my God he was having I had a uh I had uh
I did a weekend Roundup because we did
it last night and so we were we were all
going we I was like oh okay during the
indictments or what yeah so oh wow
basically what happened is I I went on
and I was like you know it's probably
gonna drop in like a couple hours uh you
know we'll just like chat through kind
of what's going on and then the
indictment drop at the very end of the
show The indictment dropped so we went
over a little bit of it uh you know
funny Willis still hadn't gone on and I
think it was like another 30 minutes or
so until she finally went on but it was
it was fun I mean you know we had a fair
amount of people in there where uh
watching as these things happen live and
just kind of recapping what happened
throughout the day
um
it was uh it was a ton of fun and the uh
well let me show you let me show you you
know what I'm just really disappointed
in myself here I'm actually getting this
morning my temple does not have me
blocked wow what the [__] this is
ridiculous I wanna speaking of blocks
speaking of blocks there's one person in
particular that I want to bring up right
now that has me blocked who his name
might be co-conspirator number one on
this indictment actually yeah uh yeah
because when I look when I look at when
I you know who that is yeah
oh do you have those uh you know so
y'all don't so y'all don't know they
were making fun of me last night calling
me Mr Boomer and all that others because
I actually printed the freaking
indictment in solidarity and solidarity
I also printed out the Georgia V Trump
indictment
Bonnie Willis could have narrowed it
down just to that he's [__]
it's 99 pages of who's indicted and by
what and the rest of it just says right
here look it says Trump is [__]
so on uh there's there's a there's a I
gotta go back to the page where it is
but I have it in this tweet
because Tom fitton
I believe Tom Finn
is uh
uh is co-conspirator number one this is
this is the person who who wrote the or
the draft letter of hey
uh let's overturn the election okay so
does he have you blocked so he has you
blocked right he has yeah he has me he's
got me blocked too I think oh yeah I'm
blocked yeah he's the one in there
because it says on or about the fourth
day of November 2020 Donald John Trump
made a nationally televised speech
falsely declaring victory in the 2020
presidential election approximately four
days earlier on or around October 31st
2020 Donald John Trump discussed a draft
speech with unindicted co-conspirator
individual one whose identity is known
to the grand jury that falsely declared
victory in falsely claimed voter fraud
that speech was an overact and further
furtherance of the conspiracy now
there's one person
going back through the documents and
going back to the hearings and
everything that was highlighted this
person Tom fitton the fake lawyer sent
an email to the White House saying on
October 31st Halloween said there was an
election and we won now there's a long
bigger part of the email it's it's
entered into evidence you can read it
yourself
um from the Committee hearing
but on there he says on on October 3rd
or on October 31st he says there was an
election and we won
now I would have loved to get his in his
input and his take on this however Tom
fitton has me blocked for a variety of
reasons uh most of them being the ones
that are listed here I was on a Twitter
spaces
and yeah I think we're both on that call
wouldn't it wouldn't it the one where
him and Seb were both in there
uh this one was about no this one was a
there was this was later on this was
later this is later on this one was
about because I had I had I had covered
in before I know what was that and did
some other stuff but in this one in
particular I was on a Twitter spaces and
the question was around like uh DeSantis
versus Trump and I said hey keep doing
what you guys are doing split the vote
all about that right and then I said uh
I find it hilarious that people keep
coming on here
that are this very people that tried to
overturn the 2020 election
Tom Finn Jenna Ellis both of those
people don't like the fact that they get
called out on these spaces and when they
do they play victim and they go oh no
that's not fair you shouldn't attack me
Jenna Ellis in particular got very upset
when I called her off for being censured
in the state of Colorado for having to
admit that she lied on 10 different
occasions about the 2020 election and
Tom Finn in particular I said I find it
funny then Tom fitton is giving input on
you know these in these pending
indictments at the time it was these
pending indictments or the the legal
proceedings that will follow Donald
Trump leading into the election because
this is the very guy who sent an email
on October 31st of the white house
before before the election day and said
there was an election and we won and
then he got all all [__] pissed off
and said oh yeah have you read the full
email have you read the full email and I
go yeah I did well then quote me the
what the rest of it says and I go no I
don't have to I don't have to quote
because I know of what you intended and
what your whole mode was behind
so don't get all [__] in your
britches right now because you're
getting called out for being a [__]
traitor and he's like oh no this what is
it with these ad hominem attacks and
this and that I was like these no this
is the truth these are the facts you did
this guy with the last name Sanchez
well you know you know because I was
there when when you were talking to uh
Mr uh I wear my sister's little shirt uh
Tom Fenton and he got he got so pissed
off so quickly and the one thing is what
you say here is because you alluded to
the fact that he's not a lawyer and he's
giving legal advice which here's what I
think if he is the co-conspirator number
one who helped draft this letter
that mean what that means is this entire
time including the time that you were
speaking to him on that call on Twitter
spaces he was he turned States evidence
against Trump in Fulton County because
there's to me there's no way other than
Tom went down there and testified and
did some kind of a deal by being under
oath about this specific period of time
in these specific emails and these
specific Communications if that is the
case then he did some kind of deal and
there's 30 other [__] well 29
other [__] other than Tom and
that's who it is that who did deals
Texas Paul because I think that's the
question here like that's the really big
question to me it's like there's no
question of that they tried to steal the
election there's no question of how they
tried to do it we know what they tried
to do we heard the [__] call from
Brad rathus Mathis pattisberger right
the Secretary of State and we we heard
that days before January 6. we knew that
phone call and the reason why is because
Trump intimidated the Secretary of State
Brad this path to samanthus Burger on
the phone to try to overturn the and
then his name and then they say it
that's exactly how it is and I right I
think I get a resellable that's his
government name right I think so that's
his legal legal name anyways you know we
know that Donald Trump did that and the
reason why is because Donald Trump
basically said in a tweet the weekend
before January 6 that Tuesday he said
hey even Brad Roethlisberger is on my
side and Brad's like nope [__]
no I'm not here's the phone call here's
the phone call you tried to intimidate
me and that's when that's when the
secretary of state of Georgia released
that phone call to the media because he
had it recorded and he released the
whole [__] he was not shy about
it and the reason why Texas Paul is
because of Rico charges Brad knows
Florida law or excuse me Georgia law and
because he knows Georgia law Brad's like
wait nope not gonna go down that
criminal Road I'm gonna cut this off
right now before it even happens because
I think Brad rattlsberger actually seen
writing on the wall that maybe a lot of
America didn't see that this guy was
desperate and he would have done
anything to remain in power Texas Paul
but that's the thing
is the question to me is not what
actually happened because we know a lot
of this already from the January 6th
select hearings and we know we know it
from just the evidence that's out there
in the public because people trying to
save their ass against Donald Trump
because everything he touches turns the
liquid [__] but here's the thing is I
want to know and the question is who are
these 30 co-conspirators we know several
of them are the actual fake electors I
think that's I think that's a given
right don't you think Texas fall
you're you're muted there you're muted
I didn't meet me I don't know maybe he
gave me today I didn't three quick
points one unlike Temple underneath my
hat I have glorious hair
[Laughter]
who I am not blocked by Tom fitton
because y'all make fun of Tom fitting
for his shirts
I happen to know he wears shirts that
are too tight because he is poor and
wearing the same shirts that he had in
college oh okay I mailed him he went to
college he went to college okay well I
mailed him a shirt that actually fits
therefore he has not blocked me
um the the 30 unnamed unindicted
co-conspirators uh most people call them
Witnesses
about 20 of them are going to be
Witnesses they are the others you've got
guys like exactly Gabe is Right Tom
fitton is one of them uh there's also
another list that I've seen circulated
around that absolutely hits for me
that's Jim Jordan Brian Babin Andy Biggs
Matt Gates Louis Gomer Paul goes our
Marjorie Taylor green Andy Harris Jody
High Scott Perry they were all at the
December 21st meeting planning meeting
for the the the Insurrection they were
all part of it so what about lady G what
about lady G where do you think Lindsey
Graham Falls in this uh this spectrum of
treasonous [__]
I think all of those that are still in
office right now are going to be
superseding indictments and it's going
to be secondary to this trial because as
you were saying earlier just jury
selection alone in this trial is going
to be
I mean it's there aren't going to be 18
separate legal separate sets of council
because a lot of these people will will
have the same Council like the three
jackasses I've got the I forget who
they're uh got to look at the list here
I've highlighted them
um the three jackasses it was uh Stephen
Clifford Clifford Lee Harrison William
Prescott Floyd and uh trevian cootie
cootie we got cheese bro and cootie
Jesus these people but they're gonna all
probably all have the same counsel
because they were part of intimidating
Ruby Freeman and and you know what I
mean so yeah
that's only if the judge will allow them
to have the same counsel because my
understanding is Georgia State law they
can allow them to have the same counsel
if the judge so will let them if the
judge says no you cannot you cannot have
the same counsel you have to have
separate counsel it is possible so so
there's there's a lot of things we don't
know you made earlier Tony right spot on
those three are flipping oh yes three
are flipping immediately you've seen
this before they bring these big Rico
indictments and and once you're in it's
it's really different when you wake up
in the morning and you're like
wait my name's on that list you know I
mean right right it's a very different
world all of a sudden you know well
because these weren't political
operators right these these people were
they and I I hate to say it like this
but this is the truth they thought they
thought they could go give them
Blackness down Ruby Freeman and her
daughter oh we'll send we'll send some
high-profile Blackness down there to
convince them to do what they should do
that's really what it was I I hate to
say it right out loud but that's the
[__] truth that's what the hell they
did that's what Trump's team was trying
to do they were like look we'll just try
to trick them into being oh yeah you
part of the Kanye West type thing and
because it was Kanye West publicist that
went down there that's one of the ones I
don't remember which name it is but
that's one of the ones that's [__]
indicted for intimidating we watched
that video because it was really weird
in real time we're like why the [__] is
Kanye West's publicist going down an
intimidating election worker in Fulton
County like it was really weird real
time and the reason why it seemed real
weird is because we didn't know their
overall plan but their overall plan was
to get election workers on Trump's side
to be part of the conspiracy right
that's what they wanted they wanted
someone to become part of the conspiracy
and when Ruby Freeman and Shay Moss told
them to [__] off and pound sand that's
when they really dug in and started to
attack them
and I mean yeah
it's not not a great move to go down and
try to threat like stalk and threaten
two people right because it's you know
we all have to remember that
Rudy Giuliani and Donald Trump went on
this tirade and torched their reputation
by saying the thing that was handed off
was a was a thumb drive it was a thumb
drive with illegal votes and it was
there to throw off the election
no it was just a [__] Ginger mint
that's all that it was it wasn't some
thumb drive it wasn't holding millions
of votes it wasn't gonna [__] throw
off the election it's the same thing
like the one person in Iowa at the State
Fair who said I hope you're ready for a
three p 2016 2020 2024 it doesn't
[__] matter it doesn't [__] matter
that one state will not overturn a whole
election when you lose the popular votes
and the Electoral College when a state
only has a handful of votes it's not
going to change anything and so when
they say oh well Georgia was the thing
that really brought Trump's chances down
because these people were stealing
because overnight all of a sudden three
million the big dump all these votes
came out of nowhere no Trump lost
and it was a ginger mint that a mother
and a daughter were exchanging that's
all that it was and and they were going
to use that as their blackmail right to
say oh we saw you do what you did wink
and if you don't and if you don't be on
our side we don't care if it was a
ginger Mint or a [__] thumb drive
we're gonna we're gonna press our base
against you and we're gonna bring
intimidation to you and now there's uh
they've already settled one defamation
lawsuit right and there were others that
are out against them right because these
these two women are not able to go to
their their actual normal lives that
were once before they even said during
the Jantz experience they're like we're
afraid to use our real names in public
after that happened we couldn't go to
the grocery store and use our names
because we were afraid that people would
either know who we were or would hear
our names and know who we were right
well uh let me show you let's go back to
Temple real quick because here's his
post an hour ago no one except 2024.
listen dude that is the problem that
you're in man see the the problem that
you have is you're not accepting that
you lost that's the problem see when you
don't do that and then you do everything
in your power to try to overturn your
loss you you you step into the bounds of
felonies and when you step into bounds
of felonies it's probably likely that
you'll be prosecuted because that's the
other [__] that that Charlie Kirk
was saying last night let me see if I
can find that and let's not forget that
Tim Poole was one of the people that
were telling everyone to show up on
January 6th he was promoting and
platforming Donald he was in the January
6th select hearings oh no I know and it
was yeah that was it was it was clips
from his show where he was he was
quoting and he was promoting Donald
Trump's message he goes this is the last
chance that Trump supporters have in
terms of fighting this election it's
going to be wild Donald Trump said that
and I believe it truly will be and this
was actual evidence presented into the
hearings of what people were saying and
who they were listening to and why they
did the things that they did it wasn't
just because like oh people showed up
and then that was it it was because
people were told to show up and Tim
Poole was one of these [__] cucks
that were hiding behind their computer
and their webcam telling people to go do
this and then later on being like oh
whoa whoa whoa I mean okay I have
millions of followers or listeners just
because I say something doesn't mean
that I actually meant it it's like
that's not it works well here's his
buddy Charlie Kirk he says there are no
more rubicons to cross last night he
said that I said did he did he thank you
for the buses of insurrectionist yet
like I think that's a Rubicon right yeah
like that's a Rubicon of Donald Trump
thanking thanking Charlie Kirk
personally for the insurrectionist that
that he bust uh to the Capitol Texas
Paul I mean this is all ridiculous this
Civil War talk this thumping of the
chest from these Cuts don't you think
are they're not gonna do [__] Texas Paul
are they they're not gonna do [__] man I
keep telling people this January 6th had
an objective and there was
a a safe Zone on the other side of it
for them if they succeeded they were all
going to be you know safe no problem
there wasn't gonna you know and there
was something to achieve Donald Trump
was still going to be the president
nobody has this right now there's
nothing they can achieve if they Riot
Donald Trump still goes to jail
if they murder somebody Donald Trump
still goes to jail
there's nothing they can achieve but
destroying their own lives right now
so no they're not going to show up they
aren't going to show up plus you have
the leaders that were involved with it
you know like Enrique tario still
waiting on his his uh sentencing do you
think he's going to stick his head up no
no way you know you got Elmer Rhodes
who's sitting in prison making freaking
license plates right now the next set of
license plates you buy might come from
Elmer freaking Rhodes man I mean just
these it's over it's over and that's why
I love what you were talking about the
you know this upcoming thing was it like
Friday I think it is they're going to do
that stupid Mike Lindell thing oh yeah
let's do that let's do more of those
how stupid maggots are
didn't provide information during the
election when it could have helped him
didn't provide information after the
election
when it could have helped him
politically
but next Friday next Friday if you send
Mike Lindell some money
they're gonna show you you were right
all along man you were right all along
I mean we can't forget that in 2021 he
did his uh cyber Symposium yeah
with Steve I mean we have to remember
what happened I mean that was it was
quite the event he didn't feed people he
played the same 15-minute trailer
multiple times because they had multiple
technical technical difficulties while
they were there uh which obviously is
ironic uh which by the way I just want
to bring up the irony of this indictment
Rudy Giuliani who made a career of going
against the mob using Rico as U.S
attorney has now found himself in an
indictment under Rico charges well you
learn from the best you learn from the
best apparently it's it's amazing but
but this cyber Symposium Mike Lindell
did this he owes the other guy who by
the way is a trump supporter owes the
guy five million dollars that guy
probably will never see the five million
dollars it's it's it's gonna be
something uh
he's already lost I think over 140
million if it costs the 100 million that
he lost because they did a canceled
culture on us and that's his words
exactly then the 40 million dollars he
invested additional money into this
election Summit which we're about to see
it's insane how much money this guy has
and how much money he's willing to burn
and just like goes out to the lawn
throws on the kerosene lights a match
that's really the easiest part to it
about me about Mike Lindell is how
Donald Trump tricked him into spending
his entire fortune on him like I
understand like Donald Trump you know
grifting these Fox News viewers and he's
Owen and Newsmax viewers you know that
they just don't understand certain
things they just don't have a certain
amount of sophistication and maybe I'm
overestimating uh Mike lindell's
sophistication here that's a possibility
but here's the thing it's like he has
spent hundreds of millions of dollars in
the name of Donald Trump and produced no
result whatsoever none like not even not
even a result that would that would give
him the ability to say I accomplished
something like nothing there's nothing
that Mike Lindell has received for this
entire thing I mean he did lose his
business he's like having to sell it all
it's pretty funny to see these people
who are like retail salesmen right you
you've got Mike Lindell who is who had
the ear and wanted to have martial law
you had the former CEO of
Costco.com which which is funny because
overstock.com paid 21 million dollars to
buy the rights the name of Bed Bath and
Beyond who formally
had my pillow as a product and then so
it's funny to see this whole thing again
a former CEO of Bed Bath Beyond or of
overstock.com
and I remember when we called him out
every overstock.com was like we just
want everyone know this the former CEO
he's right right he's the CEO this guy's
[__] crazy who had an affair with a
Russian spy yeah patina well I mean they
you know they do this they get Chinese
spies they get Russian spies on their
side uh and then they buy uh they buy
buses
um
um so Gabe here is uh here is Charlie
Kirk again and this is their plan
right this is their civil this is their
first battle of action right in the new
Civil War in the Twitter comments
because I believe that's really new new
Civil War right right right right right
so Charlie here says the only way this
stops is if we start indicting criminal
Democrats okay there's plenty to choose
from all right go ahead well I don't
know what you're talking about if you've
got a case to make against a Democrat do
by all means go indict them and take
them to trial and court and convict them
like this do it do it
do it do it no way so um he's he goes on
to ask the question because here's
and I don't know like they run into the
point every time like every single time
he's like will a single D.A an attorney
general step up no the reason why is
because they generally want careers as
prosecutors they also need evidence well
well there's that too yeah right but I
mean like it's not just like hey I'm
just a I'm a nobody infomercial attorney
this is a D.A a district attorney who
represents people of a district or who
are elected and attorney generals who
are elected too these are people who
have real positions they they have to
determine what cases they're going to
handle for the general public for the
people they represent and they have a
ton of people that work under them these
are not just like hey I have a law firm
or hey I'm just a lawyer on the side or
whatever these are legitimate lawyers
people who have hopes of having high
repositions in administrations or larger
positions going forward these are not
people who are willing to throw away
their career on some non-evidence
type of claim that people what are these
people gonna come against the Democrats
okay well do you have evidence do you
have a case if so bring it forward to
these people bring it forward to the D.A
in the Attorney General I would love for
them to laugh you out of the [__]
room because that is what they're going
to do every single time well that the
way it's gonna go is the way it went for
Rudy Giuliani in these Federal cases
right after the election Texas Paul it's
the it's the same thing because he went
Rudy Giuliani would go to Four Seasons
Landscaping and you know as [__] the
[__] was melting out of his temples and
[__] and the media the media every
Network every Network and listen the
thing is is that Denny would get into
court open court and we were during the
pandemic so they were doing it a lot via
Zoom call but he would say in open court
to the federal judge when they would ask
him is there any evidence of Fraud and
Rudy Giuliani had to say no and the
reason why is because if he would have
said yes the judge would have said Okay
show it to me and he would have been
able he would have had to say what he
told Rusty Bowers well I got it it's
just in a suitcase somewhere in
Washington you know and the rusty Bowers
was really suspicious at that point but
a federal judge would tell Rudy John
Rudy Giuliani to step it up his ass
right if if a federal judge asked her to
Johnny to provide him evidence of what
he's saying and he didn't provide it the
judge would say well then you don't have
any [__] evidence then and here's the
thing here's here's Charles Chucky
Charlie Kirk here's Charles throwing out
more rakes okay when they say stupid
[__] like this folks when their
narrative is that we want now we're
going to get retribution by by by
[__] having local County DA's
prosecute Joe Biden do it [__] do it
dummies go for it the reason why they
can't exactly what Gabe Sanchez says the
exactly the reason why the House
Republicans are having such a [__] a
problem with their unpopularity and
that's why they're going to shut down
the governments because they're so
goddamn unpopular there's nothing more
that you can do for your popularity than
to be more unpopular than you are today
and the thing is let them throw these
rakes out and [__] jump on them
encourage them yeah do it do it go for
it [__] [__] indict somebody let's
see it come on the one thing I was in uh
just really quickly I was going through
footage of the the infamous uh Rudy
leaking hair uh uh conference that he
had with Jen Ellis who's also uh
honestly and Sydney and Sydney Powell I
mean God it's amazing to see this thing
come full circle but when I look I went
through the footage and I was watching
because I was like oh I gotta find
footage of Rudy wiping his his snot and
then wiping his face uh because uh Ron
DeSantis learned from the best obviously
and in that conference Rudy Giuliani
says we have affidavits we have
affidavits signed affidavits of people
that said that this election fraud was
happening and he could say all he wants
in a press conference and claim that
they have affidavits but as soon as you
said you know as soon as they showed up
to court or they were on the zoom call
and the judge said great you have a case
awesome what are the what's the evidence
it goes well it's not evidence per se
it's just a lot of theories feel so it
feels like like I feel like I can feel
you know when like in your bones when
you can feel like it's about to rain
that's me right now with these crimes
that are happening and it's really the
only crime is Rudy Giuliani claiming
that people stole the election
go ahead Texas Paul I tell you this and
actually what you were talking about
with Charlie Hurricane regions he is not
the only one saying this stuff
the only way we stop this is to indict
Democrats this and no we are not
indicting our political opponent we are
indicting a criminal a criminal you
people you Republicans are so far out in
the [__] about what you're doing with
your life you have Ron DeSantis who just
removed a a duly elected prosecutor in
the state of Florida
because she was a Democrat
no no much because she's a black woman
she's a black woman
and it you know they're doing things
Tony that are just so far over the pail
over the line they try to steal an
election and their point of view is well
we we the way we stop these Democrats
from stopping us from stealing elections
is to throw some Democrats in jail bring
it on [__] bring it on you really want
violence you really want violence try it
try it we you know Democrats are very
different people we don't us we're not
freaking temp pools we don't walk around
everything civil war Civil War no we
don't we're like the system works the
system works we will work through the
system even the broken parts of the
system the gerrymandering will just show
up and vote
but you take this step
Republicans you listen to Charlie idiot
child groomer Kirk
that's where violent happened violence
happens
you know they they'll start with
protests they will start with complaints
and it will escalate into extreme
violence because then you have taken our
democracy away and the beautiful thing
about democracy isn't the winning it's
the losing
the beautiful part about democracy is
the loser concedes to the winner and we
don't have to kill each other
it is non-violent War that's what
democracy is we're not killing each
other we're not attacking each other
we're following the law and the loser
concedes
and issues legitimacy to the next
government the GOP is great with just
completely trying to delegitimize our
entire government you know when this
happened in 2000 and Al Gore had
legitimate complaints Al Gore stood up
and said we have a president
we will get behind that President this
government is legitimate
and then he stepped back and he went
away that's democracy that is how
democracy works it doesn't you know and
and these
trumpers have been given opportunity
after opportunity after opportunity
court case after court case to to make
their cases you know Mike Lindell and
his [__] grip that's gonna happen
this week
um I can't wait for that that rake and
Tony's Tony's right televise it
on I mean yeah cut in every major
Network offer them free freaking cameras
you know how fast they will shut this
down
if ABC CBS and NBC says we're gonna have
our Network Primetime cameras there
well here's Donald Trump's uh little
fraud social post about what you're
talking about uh on I guess it's gonna
be Monday is it yeah Monday he says a
lot a large complex oh [__] here we go
detailed but irrefutable report he puts
report in capitals I don't I don't get
this game but listen number one and
we're not even through the first
sentence and he says large complex and
detailed there is nothing there is
nothing that Donald Trump has ever done
that is large
but I also want to point out something
here the third word here complex
if you are innocent and this is all a
Witch Hunt right then it should not be
complex it should be easy and
straightforward right to prove that you
are innocent well but that's also it's
taken him two and a half years to make
this [__] where has he been what he's
been doing that's what I've been saying
about the reason why they want to make
the hunter Biden thing so complex is
because they want dumb people to feel
smart yeah they want to go so it's look
dude oh yeah right you can't understand
it you wouldn't understand it it takes a
it takes right a doctor done in Krueger
to really understand the effects of this
right here I'm sorry I'm sorry that you
your little brain doesn't understand all
of the nuances of the legal system okay
I had a shirt made just for Hunter
Biden's stories
what does it say I really don't care do
you oh it's the Melania jacket exactly
exactly
especially for Hunter Biden's stories
every time there's a breaking news story
about Hunter Biden I am going to wear
this shirt on that segment but he's
already he's already telling you in this
first few words a large complex detail
and irrefutable report what he's saying
is oh it looks fancy but it's all
[__] yeah like he's saying it out
loud just like the the right Hunter
Biden Joe Biden right exactly yeah the
house Judiciary Committee makes it's
just regurgitated information that we've
already heard and has been debunked but
you throw around a couple sentences
rearrange the paragraphs you call it a
different buzzwords it's a different
thing entirely right right the Kraken
Sydney Powell is in this indictment yeah
for this [__] right that is how she
ended up in this indictment did she
believe at one point that Hugo Chavez
yeah [__] yeah something about the
machines in Italy or something [__]
I don't know because I just watched this
video the other day the whole way it
works is
the votes were sent to Germany
wait wait wait wait I thought it was
Italy
Germany
in Germany
so we vote here in America they go to
Germany German the company is owned uh
by talking about Dominion yeah yeah okay
then you go down to uh then you connect
with Hugo Chavez right yeah and then
you're like wait but he's I don't have
my red string yeah but then you're like
he but he died like how many years 13
years prior to this right then you're
like how is he the one in control well
they had to dig him up with the space
lasers okay
it's kind of like in uh what was the
deep blue sea where they like you know
bring out the they undo the the brain of
the shark and they hit the laser to like
hit a new part of it to make them
smarter and then like oh [__] we
shouldn't have done that it's like the
complete opposite they made themselves
even [__] Dumber oh Jesus Christ well
he goes on to say because I can't wait
for Grandpa to try to explain what
you're explaining here because it
doesn't make sense when you a smart
person is trying to explain it let alone
it's insane and like Texas ball said we
don't have enough string to connect just
from Germany to Venezuela to Hugo Chavez
the Trump Ryan to Hunter Biden to Nancy
Pelosi all the way up to Barista Justin
Trudeau you know it's it doesn't Justin
Trudeau
okay he's Donald Trump definitely
doesn't Trudeau because the Milani wants
to [__] yeah
she wants the Canadian bacon right oh is
that what it is okay I mean that's why
that makes sense that makes sense the
old ham that oh ham hock he's got huh uh
on the presidential election fraud which
took place in Georgia yeah we know
election fraud took place in Georgia we
we've seen the indictment last night you
dumb [__] he says is almost
complete and will be presented by me oh
great you're gonna present this thing
that sounds fantastic at a major news
conference at 11 A.M on Monday of next
week in Bedminster New Jersey this
sounds fantastic honestly this sounds
like more crime is gonna happen and he's
gonna get more indictments for this
thing this is great when is it supposed
to happen on Monday yeah Monday at 11
A.M 11 A.M why we're on why why we're on
well right after one air because it'll
be 11 A.M and an hour later we'll be on
air so we'll actually be able to [__]
mock him and make fun of him on this
beautiful fantastic
um he says basically you know what
actually I have a conspiracy theory
about this though yeah what okay let's
get our tin foil heads up go ahead there
is because he's already coming out and
attacking Witnesses and already come
like he went after Duncan yesterday and
I actually think that they're trying to
set this up
to get a judge to tell them they can't
do this
so they've got this conspiracy theory
that the government will not let you
know
with all the evidence on it uh a
thumbnail is it like an actual thumbnail
with Like Cocaine caked on it or is it
like a thumb drive which is it which is
it it's gonna be like a thumb drive with
with
the trailer that Gabe was talking about
earlier and I have another conspiracy
theory about that Mike Lindell did not
spend that money Mike Lindell sent that
money overseas and I can't prove this
you can't sue me like what money what
money this is this is unproven I'm
telling you it's a legend but all the
millions you know all the millions of
dollars that he claimed to spend on that
project where he was going to put it
again the reason they played the trailer
over and over and over and over again
because there was nothing it wasn't a
technical problem there was nothing more
than that trailer made and they kept the
rest of the cash
that money is sitting down in the uh
what what is it in Bahamas or something
the Caymans yeah or or it's with Google
oh yeah that makes sense that makes
sense when they when they buried him up
with the space lasers there was a hole
in the ground so they buried it in that
hole where exactly yeah Hugo he's just
been underground this whole time waiting
for this very moment to present himself
and say
suckers do you see how crazy this
Margaritas we have just been talking 20
minutes 20 minutes about their [__]
stupid conspiracy theories there are
people folks listen to me when I tell
you turn it up there are people out
there that believe this [__] they
believe this nonsense
what the [__] hey you you remember you
remember those uh those uh those
um those metal objects that were
appearing all over the country yeah just
like this the the the the they were just
like out of nowhere right and they're
like oh are they aliens
what were they calling them they're
calling them what the hell they call
them I don't know I'm blinking I'm sure
someone in the chat will remind us I'm
thinking on the name right now but
anyways at the Chinese weather balloons
they were the metal they were like these
like men are poles like like
triangular metal columns that were
randomly modeling monoliths Spicy Dragon
has it here yeah yeah
we're showing up all over the world
right and our chat is so [__] smart
by the way you [__] I'm glad
they're on the same wavelength there but
anyway these model is my theory my
theory is that the monoliths had shown
up in all of these key parts of the
world because at the time they were
holding all of the votes okay well what
what these people believe this no no
that's just I wouldn't be surprised if
they didn't believe it at one point I
believe that the monoliths were holding
all of different vaccines for covid at
the same time but I really believe the
monoliths okay
the monolith showed up in 2020
everyone's like where do these come from
oh my God can you find me a picture of
this thing find me a picture of this
thing so we can show everybody so at the
time these things were showing up and
they were like oh this is so weird but
like what about what's on the inside
okay what could you store on the inside
I don't know a bunch of documents maybe
a bunch of votes you know if I had to
say
uh I mean look look
maybe they controlled the space lasers I
don't know could have been Beacon
devices I have no idea I truly believe
that triangulate the the satellites so
the lasers could be pointed in a certain
direction to change votes or something
and that what I mean that's what that's
what they said I mean you know connects
Italy to Germany to Venezuela back to
the U.S to dominion smartmatic and
collusion with Rudy Giuliani being the
true person that was able to identify
this this Con that was happening okay
he's the only one that was able to
connect the dots and those dots were
that these monoliths connected and had
and stored physically all of the
high-tech mermaids made in monoliths
that's possibility but I truly believe
that these monoliths that these
monoliths contained all of the votes
that were needed to overturn the
election millions of votes Joe Biden got
81 million votes you kidding me no no it
was in the monoliths right it was the
monolith and they're probably woke too
by the way yeah but I can't wait for
Grandpa to explain all these conspiracy
theories just it's gonna be fantastic he
goes on to say based on the results of
this conclusive I know why does he yell
uh in in the middle of because if you
yell if you yell then people listen
that's what he thinks okay conclusive
report all charges should be dropped
against me and others not all the other
people just some of the others just some
just all put some right there will be
complete exoneration
there will they never went after those
that rigged the election
of what they only went after those who
fought to find the riggers whoa dude
with the heart with the hard R's dude
grandpa with the hard R's you're getting
close man he came so close I really want
him to say the word he came so close in
this in this one here at the very end
here's the thing here's the thing how in
the [__] okay bear with me on this how
in the [__] with exoneration is him
going out in front of the [__]
country and he's gonna make a fool out
of himself and then he's uh not gonna be
exonerated because that's not what's
going to happen we all know that
um how the [__] does he explain this
after that like whoa I thought I know
how oh deep State deep State yeah of
course Facebook was the monolith here
click the link and I'll show you click
the link and let me blow everything it's
not working right it's not working click
the second click the second one
oh there it is okay yeah again all right
this is what I'm talking about people
these structures these beautiful silver
reflective structures this is where the
things that held all of the secrets to
20. how many were there how many were
there there were like 18 or something
that showed up there's some number all
over the country all the country or all
of the world actually just popped out of
the ground like that yeah just they just
popped up maybe or maybe not it was a
hoax I don't know but definitely
they are the reason that we had this
election and also coveted vaccines they
had everything it was everything that
the the secrets of the world the
universe were held in these monoliths
and some of the secrets were the 2020
election do you think it could have been
Mike Lindell that went around and put up
all these monoliths no that's what he
was doing no I don't know because if it
was I feel like it would be around
tinfoil hat not oh okay I got you this
is why I tell people like people that
are in your audience in my audience that
they have to vote every damn election
because there are people on this planet
that believe
the Earth is flat they believe these
conspiracy theories Gabe's talking about
that was a big deal the monolith thing
when you showed the picture I knew
exactly what you're talking that was a
big deal they really believed this was
something magical happening you've got
people
after 9 11 they figured you know what we
need to beef up our radiation detection
so you'll drive down the highway and all
of a sudden you'll see an arc over your
Highway that's just about Bridge height
you know just under bridge height so
that a truck can just get underneath it
the radiation detectors
people freaked the hell out over these
things and we're literally causing
accidents swerving to get in between the
radiation detectors so that the
government couldn't keep track of them
and the chips they had put in their
brains or whatever the hell else they
were doing to track them are these the
same people who want Elon to put a chip
in their brain because it feels like a
vote for Donald Trump Tony and vote for
they show the hell up Cesar mayak the
the bummer the Trump bomber Caesar mayak
did you see his van he was living out of
it was freaking scary man it was covered
from ground to roof with bumper stickers
that were all freaking conspiracy
they're out there people and they vote
you have to vote you have to it's not
it's not in like the old days where it
was just you know the high-minded people
that paid attention and read you know
Red Barons and the you know they those
were the people that voted no no no the
Republicans figured out that they could
get to these people they could feed them
full of conspiracy theories like we're
going to show you the evidence next week
I promise and they vote man is it the
same to show up is it the same time are
we going to get the health care that he
promised we're going to get the evidence
well two weeks two weeks okay okay good
yeah but I just want to I guess
infrastructure is going to kick in oh
okay good I want to point out Texas Paul
mentioned 9 11. do you know which
candidate that is running on the
Republican party right now is a 911
denier
a a Republican or Democrat a Republican
which I am going to say it's DeSantis
nope
who is he's right behind DeSantis is it
Vivek yeah
he was on Alex Stein's show he was on
Alex Stein's show wait stop stop he went
on Alex nine show that's all you gotta
say he won an Alex Stein show oh you
guys and Alex time was like okay quick
rapid fire reveck was the moon landing
real or fake and he was like I have no
reason to believe that it wasn't like
real so I believe it was real and he
goes 911 inside job or like did the
government lie to us and he goes I don't
believe that we have all the facts and I
was like all right oh Jesus Christ what
a [__] bonehead well speaking of
boneheads last night there was a lot of
calls on on [__] Trader TV's news
networks when these indictments hit
because here's the thing these are State
charges which is a big problem for a
person who is trying to run for
president to Pardon himself from
felonies because a president can only
pardon themselves from federal felonies
not State felonies so it's gonna be a
problem right well last night and the
Republicans knew this right away they're
like oh this is really bad and the
reason why is because even if he wins to
be the president he cannot pardon
himself so what is the president going
to be in a Georgia State Prison running
the government I don't know but last
night they were like oh what we need to
do is have this was their solution I
think three or four of these
[__] said this stupid [__] we
need to get the Georgia legislator to
change the law so that way Brian Kemp
can pardon Trump of this nonsense oh my
God my God you people it's the same
stupid [__] when you say dumb [__] like
we're gonna get cameras in a federal
courtroom it's not a thing hey it's not
a thing the other thing too is Brian
campus spoke to this this morning he
tweeted this just over an hour ago and
it's a response to his to Donald Trump's
little I'm gonna be exonerated when I
read you this stupid ass report that I
don't even understand because it's
[__] nonsense here's Brian Kemper the
[__] he's the governor this guy is the
[__] governor of floor excuse me
Georgia Florida Georgia Line let's just
let's just remind everyone that the it's
the Republicans that were brought in to
tell us or to tell uh funny Willison and
the grand jury whether or not the
election was stolen the claims were real
all these things the Republicans are the
ones who have been brought in okay you
had Jeffrey or Jeff or however you say
his name spell his name Jeff I don't
know how to spell my first name and then
you've got Brian Kemp okay you got
Governor lieutenant governor Republicans
these people are of of large High uh
level of of of power and influence and
the state of of of Georgia
and these are the ones who are literally
telling you right now
Trump lied it wasn't stolen right move
the [__] on because you guys are about
to find the [__] out well here's the
thing the re the thing that really
pisses Brian Kemp and Jeff I don't know
how to spell my first name Duncan off is
he he lost them two [__] Senate seats
there are two Democrats who are United
States senator in their state because of
trump and that [__] gets in their
crawl like a [__] I mean a
[__] because they got to
cooperate with the federal government
through their state senators in that way
with Democrats not with [__]
Republicans which is a problem but for a
fascist it's a problem for people who
are interested in democracy they can
find a way to compromise and work it out
but fascists like Brian Kemp and Jeff I
don't know how to spell my first name
Duncan have a problem with it but here's
Brian Kemp this morning he says the 2020
election in Georgia was not stolen for
nearly three years now anyone with
evidence of fraud has failed to come
forward
under oath he says and prove anything
anything in a court of law our elections
in Georgia are secure accessible and
fair and will continue to be as long as
I am Governor the future of our
countries at stake in 2024 and that must
be our focus and he's basically saying
Hey [__] off grandpa but he's not gonna
[__] off but Tony Tony is there not a
D.A or an attorney general who will come
forward and bring these Democrats to
Justice no no no
that's what has Trump's all twisted up
he's got another one of these posts out
here on Truth social I am reading
reports that failed former lieutenant
governor of Georgia Jeff Duncan
misspells his first name we'll be
testifying before the Fulton County
grand jury he shouldn't I barely know
him
but he was right from the beginning of
this Witch Hunt a nasty disaster for
those looking into the election fraud
that took place in Georgia he refused
having a special session to find out
what went on that is what really has
Trump's super freaking pissed off
because Brian Kemp
I hate the guy but at least he and
Duncan didn't fall into this [__] they
they were trying to get them to hold a
special session in the Georgia
legislature well it's the same thing
they were doing [__] electors up it's
the same thing we're doing with Rusty
Bowers in Arizona and the problem is is
that they need what they needed what
they needed was evidence to trigger a
special session and they didn't have it
and here's here's Jeff I don't know how
to spell my first name Duncan now look
this guy's no [__] hero okay listen
[__] this guy [__] this guy he's a
coward he should have said in December
when they were pressuring them to do
this [__] they should have got out in
front of a microphone like the
lieutenant like the lieutenant secretary
or excuse me the deputy deputy secretary
of state did I forget his name right off
hand he was one of the ones that
testified yesterday for like two [__]
hours but he got out in front of a
microphone if you remember and he told
Trump [__] off [__] you need to stop
this [__] you know it's a bunch of
[__] [__] and you need to stop it
he was out in front of a microphone that
guy that guy I got respect for this
[__] [__] him [__] Duncan he
doesn't even know how to spell his first
name so [__] him but let's listen
yesterday this is him this is him coming
out of the courthouse and this is his
statement to the reporters there right
after he testified this is [__]
hilarious folks this tells you how what
their focus is they don't give a [__]
about the truth even this guy who now
has seen the light and come to Jesus
moment he still won't give a [__] about
The Truth Listen to this you said uh
this was a pivot point for the country
as you as you came out of the room what
do you hope your testimony accomplished
well I hope my testimony gets the facts
uh you know as they are and helps to
continue to paint a real and honest
picture but but politically oh I hope
the facts come out in the truth but [__]
the truth [__] truth that's not really
why I'm here let me tell you why I'm
actually here let's hear it you [__]
idiot speaking this is a pivot point for
this country to do something more than
just stew on the on on the 2020 election
cycle right we're either gonna as
Republicans take our medicine and
realize the election wasn't rigged
Donald Trump was the worst candidate
ever in the history of the party even
worse than Herschel Walker and now we're
gonna have to Pivot from there right we
want to win an election in 2010. okay he
thinks a big dig at Herschel there
really doesn't [__] like this guy
okay here's here's the problem here's
the problem is that what what Jeff I
don't know how to spell my first name
Duncan is saying here I know that's a
long nickname but it fits him well I'm
assuming that's why Herschel Walker was
trending yesterday yes so here's the
thing the reason why Jeff I don't know
how to spell my first name Duncan is
saying this is because he doesn't give a
[__] about the truth honestly if it
served his power if it served them
advancing the Republican Party he would
go along with the lie that's what he's
saying is look the truth is is that we
can't [__] keep losing with this
[__] idiot anymore if we would win
with him I'd be with him all the way man
if we could win with him I'd be all in
man I'd suck his you know what if it
meant we won but we can't he's a [__]
loser and because Jeff know knows the
truth here Duncan knows the truth here
he doesn't give a [__] about the truth
the actual truth that needs to be told
to the American people all he cares
about is the truth that they're going to
[__] lose because Trump's a goddamn
loser and they're too cowardly to know
what is at stake in our democracy this
[__] is not a [__] Patriot he
is not no [__] hero this Duncan this
guy is still standing after he went and
testified against the former president
United States trying to overturn our
vote our election he was the lieutenant
governor he was pressuring him to
overturn his [__] constituents votes
in his state so that he could be in
power for God knows what reason other
than to save his own ass and here is
Duncan admitting I don't care about the
facts the only reason why I'm coming
with the facts now is because we got to
get rid of trump because I want power I
want power I want Power he don't give a
[__] about matter democracy he don't
give two shits and this was not what I
was saying yesterday in my [__] rant
and my 30 minute a block is that these
people are [__] cowards Duncan Kemp
they're all [__] cowards
Mike Pence is a coward every one of them
Chris Christie's a [__] coward Where
Were You Chris Chris Christie said on on
Fox News just a couple days ago you know
what I Trump lost me when he came out
that night and said that he'd won even
though he knew it he didn't win well
where were you [__] where were
you Liz Cheney for a 190 [__] days
190 days it took her to go the house
floor and say yeah Trump lost
where the [__] were you you are cowards
the only time they turn on Trump is when
they realize they get it in their
[__] brain they get in their [__]
brain that hey we're gonna lose we're
gonna lose if we keep doing this we're
gonna lose if we keep spreading these
[__] lies that they don't give a [__]
about the lies they don't care about the
truth they only care about their own
power they don't give a [__] about the
institution of democracy they don't care
about it and yeah and they certainly
don't care about their constituents and
you know their constituents
doesn't they don't quite get it I mean
if you listen to the things that were
said to Brian Glenn on rsbn When Donald
Trump was leaving the tarmac in Iowa
there were multiple people one of one
woman was like oh he's anointed he was
sent here he's gonna fight them he you
know he never took his salary he didn't
know he did take his salary uh you know
he donated his money he did not donate
all of his money you know these are you
know he he he's fighting against the the
Democrats the corrupt the the Deep State
this and that like these people really
believe this stuff
and they truly you know and their heart
of hearts believe that Donald Trump
was wrongly persecuted in all of these
investigations and that somehow even
though they're independent jurisdictions
and they're no overlap other than Jack
Smith having two investigations but
having a team that's separated to look
at both individually even though they do
have connections
the fact that you've got Manhattan
Fulton County Mar-A-Lago DC you've got
all of these things that are happening
each one independent
independent grand juries of a variety of
ranges and people and representations of
the people that are Americans right
that's your duty
Republicans Maga whatever you want to
call them all believe that there's some
sort of collusion happening the real
collusion is between all of these
investigations between all these
different prosecutors and all these
different grand juries and these
different states entirely and they
believe that it's all a cons
united front against Trump no the the
fact is Donald Trump is a criminal he
committed crimes and now it has taken
two and a half years to see those things
come to light so when you hear people
say why did it take two and a half years
Donald Trump has been saying that
recently too yesterday and today oh two
and a half years later why didn't they
bring it two and a half years ago
it's almost like these people don't
understand how collecting evidence and
building a case works right like there's
there's it's
astonishing to see these people who are
so disconnected and broken from reality
that they'll never believe a single
thing anyone of actual truth and facts
have to say
but when it comes to Donald Trump
they'll believe everything that that
anointed savior's second coming of
Christ Christian believing God-fearing
man who didn't take any money who didn't
go in who didn't use his political
corruptness to benefit himself at all no
no no of course of course Donald Trump
is the is the innocent one here
people are mad at me because I I gave
Jeff the nickname not Chapel it's Jeff
Jeff
in the chat who's who's does not spell
it the way that I want it spelled is mad
at me listen Jeff it's it's just a joke
it's I'm just I'm just digging at him a
bit Jeff is really going to be pissed
off oh I know
hey
all of the Jeffs in the world are going
to meet up and show up to your house I
know and they're gonna they're gonna not
well not the ones that spelled the way
Jeff Duncan spells his name the way he
does because his father was very
pretentious his mother his mother Carol
passed away recently so I will not speak
ill of her but she wanted to name him
Jeff Jeffrey Jeffrey but his father his
father should do it Carol dear there are
no Jeffs in the country club we can't
name him Jeff I think compromised and
spelled it golf
listen I I I'm sorry Jeff I I it's just
a joke and I I was just [__] around
but you can you know if you don't like
he's a bully Tony is a big bully I will
I'll go after these [__]
however I can't look he I I think he
should change his name to just Duncan he
looks like a Duncan right oh his first
name is not just no well that that could
be he could it's his name it's the same
how would he spell it though would he
spell it with a G or a j just no it
would be J yeah j j u h s yeah just TT
just just Duncan just Duncan it's it's
just it's just it's just it's just
Duncan it's like it's like when I call
Matt they say Gates that's what they say
but it's gets I call him Matt Getz
because the reason why is because
because if Matt gatz ever sees a video
of me talking about Matt Getz I want him
to see that I say his [__] name wrong
[__] that guy okay so it's nothing
against you Jeff or how you spell your
name it's because Jeff Duncan is a
goddamn Republican and he's a coward but
you know that's how it goes I want to go
to this tape here uh inside the
courtroom last night all the media oh
dude they were so ready like they had
such a hard-on for what was about to
happen I mean if they were you know they
we'll talk about it after this but they
were all primed oh man these these
indictments it was throbbing it was
throbbing they got a teaser everyone got
like a little T and then they got blue
ball they're like nope
it was almost like it was almost like
the mouth right around it and right at
the last moment snatched away but watch
this this is great
that's it was it all you hoped it would
be
it was I didn't get a good look
yeah
so that's it that's it the judge looks
at him as like ah was it as good for you
as it was for me
oh my god oh man did you did you finish
too did you come I'm gonna come
do you have that clip of trump I'm gonna
go fine I can find that guy I'm gonna
give him no yeah yeah okay let me let me
look for the I'm gonna come clip I need
to have that on a sound effect I'm gonna
come though there is another one uh I've
been asked to play on the air uh right
now which is a clip of Joe Biden
give me a black screen but then it's
gonna he's gonna say something okay okay
yeah well uh where's where's it at it's
at the bottom of the brand okay let me
let me let me play it here all right
let's see
[__] em
[Music]
well uh there's I I think that's Joe
Biden's official statement yeah I mean
you know it's either catching them on
the bike hey did you follow the
indictment no you know hey what are your
thoughts on the diamond [__] up [__] em
all right let me get back to looking for
this I'm gonna come thing here's here's
the judge's face I want to show this
when he he's got the indictment here and
he's like whoa [__] me this is the look
on his face when he opened up those
indictments and he's like God damn
they're [__]
I mean how else could you interpret this
other than oh man that's not good that's
not good this is a look on his face so
this is like the only reaction that the
media really got from the judge yeah
from the case
other than he's like did you come
because I came I mean that was the only
reaction we really got from the um from
the judge inside the courtroom now we
have the the document the documents we
got the documents here
um so let me show you the the actual if
I can find it let's see we got a good
one a good post here oh yeah here we go
here's the actual indictment
um at least the cover be or the the
first page here and it gives you all the
names and then the charges this isn't
the first page no that's that's not it
that's not see see Texas fault see we
live in a digital world and I have to
show them digitally I can't you know
what text Paul print off the indictment
and then scan it in the computer and
then send it over and then I'll show
them yes
um I printed it from a scan why would I
do that it was right but that's that's
why I'm making fun of you the last 90s
like hey I'm printing the uh the
indictments for tomorrow's show I'm like
all right Boomer so as I'm making a
poking a little fun at him but I can
write on this oh okay well good good and
I'm happy that you can right on the uh
the paper so here is uh here's all right
there's white out on your computer
screen that's right yes that's why
I I don't actually write anything
anymore I I I type it down in like a
notepad like on my phone like I take all
my and I don't really take that many
notes if you can't tell
um the state of Georgia spiral notebooks
man yeah yeah well I used to use the
legal pads but I stopped at um about 10
years ago and I just started using an
iPad it says at the state of Georgia
versus uh let's see Donald Jessica Trump
uh Rudy farty uh mcsharty uh colludi
Giuliani we got uh John Eastman we got
uh Mark I'm a Trader Randall Meadows we
got uh Kenneth cheese burrow you can't
make this [__] up man cheese bro really
yeah
everybody Jeff hang in there bud it's
not it's not that bad you've got cheese
bro here trying to tell right everybody
in the world that his name is chess bro
Chester bro no no no it does not
like yeah
not it's it's dude extra extra cheese
and Mayo dude only Mayo on that
cheeseburger right well here's another
guy who actually knows how to spell Jeff
sorry Jeff in the chat I'm I'm just I'm
just playing I mean Jeffrey Jeffrey's
pantsless Clark yes well you know listen
have you ever watched the Seinfeld
episode where Kramer takes off his pants
so he doesn't crease them I actually
think that's what was happening oh got
it Jeffrey Clark was sitting down
yeah well he had his pants hanging up so
he didn't get creases in him that's why
he didn't have every night you know
Rumor Has It many people are saying
Jeffrey Clark rumor has it rumor has it
rumor Jeffrey Clark actually uh he
washes his pants every day because he
shits them oh okay well he should be
another person that should be [__]
her pants is Jenna Ellis funny you say
you say [__] yeah uh she got farted
on by Rudy colludy leaking hair uh
Giuliani right that's why you know
that's why I call him Grandpa farty
mcsharty yeah that specific moment in
history where he where he gave the covid
fart to Jenna Ellis in the face you know
what's funny about that did you know
that is that is a moment in this
indictment where Rudy Giuliani goes to
Michigan to try to convince Michigan the
same thing he was trying to convince
Arizona and Georgia to do and he had
that crazy [__] drunk lady who
cleaned the screens on the machines and
she's like I know about elections and
she was just hired to spray Windex and
clean the screens you know I'm not gonna
I got another conspiracy that crazy
drunk woman who they brought in Georgia
is the same woman who was on the plane
who's like that guy back there is not
real same same is that the same lady no
it's not it's not but I I believe in my
heart I believe I believe it truly is
yeah well here's here's another one on
here the Kraken Sydney Kraken pal can
you imagine her middle name actually oh
wow
how quickly Sydney Sydney died Dr Pepper
what was that Texas ball move on that
quickly because I mean you really have
to give props to Jenna Ellis because
Rudy Giuliani actually paused when he I
mean folks if you don't know what we're
talking about he was talking to election
officials Jenna Ellis was sitting next
to him he's speaking into the microphone
and just literally just
[Music]
loud enough that the microphone picked
it up
Jenna Ellis did not move did not blink
didn't stayed in perfect form Rudy just
literally crapped his pants sitting next
to her and she did not I mean didn't
pick up a PIN to write didn't
nothing man she just sat there and
inhaled it all in no I think I think she
did I think she did Tony pull up the
tweet uh well here let me let me do this
one first let me do this one first
I'm Gonna Come
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh there ain't that much Viagra in the
world oh I'm Gonna Come
[Applause]
oh my God I can't I can't it said too
much all right now pull up the Tweet is
this the Gina Ellis one I'll show you
the moment that Jenna Ellis knew that
she contracted oh so so so this is where
we get the moment why she's indicted
right yeah okay let's see here
uh right there
right there
[Music]
but I swear to God if you actually play
the video
she just is like a freaking Buck she
takes that Hooter right in the face
doesn't crack at all can you imagine
crack and crack him can you imagine how
bad Rudy's farts smell though I mean
really honestly you smell like death
many people say that he's actually uh
the original he's a vampire you know
he's he's the uh
the the one who creeps out from from the
from the tomb he's the one
creepy Rudy Giuliani
his his farts smell like something died
inside because he is he is dead he's uh
Nosferatu he is he is the absolute
deadest of dead when it comes to uh
souls and beans I tried to did you find
the clip yeah I get the clip here I I
have to dispute that because the guy
walked up and patted him on the back
once and Rudy pretended he died so
here's here's the moment here's the
moment it's not very long see if you can
smell it I mean catch it here it is
witness witness witness witness witness
witness
it just doesn't get oh that's how many
times he farted too that's how many
times so many so many some some people
some people say actually many people are
saying that Rudy stunk up the court that
day but not because of his frivolous
lawsuit and and debunked uh uh uh you
know evidence but it's because he
actually literally farted in the court
and they had to evacuate they're like
holy [__] we gotta get out of here and
they all [__] left they never came
back and they laughed him out of the
room
uh I just you know I kind of got a
little nauseous right there because I
started thinking about it I've never had
the displeasure of meeting Rudy Giuliani
in person but could you imagine that
mixed up smell of like hair dye and
cheap old man cologne and dead dying old
person and you know he's crapping on
himself all the time so he's like crop
dusting all the time you know he'd walk
into a room and that combined smell
would just waft into you man I do
you know what I just I just had an
epiphany uh now that you're talking
about Republican farts and how they
smell uh because I I got a clip here of
Chris Christie and
but here's the thing I just realized
this because Fox News keeps having him
on Newsmax keeps having on and he just
keeps dunking not just on Trump but on
the host because he's like you're a
[__] sicka fan Christy's literally
like you're a [__] sycophant why
would you say that the dumbest thing
I've ever heard but you know what
do you know the reason why they're
letting them on these networks and they
have to let him on these networks do you
know why he's a presidential candidate
they he's not indicted yeah well that
too but they have but they have to give
him a certain amount of air time they
have to give him a certain amount of air
time they want to get because he's a
presidential candidate because he's
requesting it I actually believe at this
point Chris Christie is really actually
running for Resident so he can be on all
these Trump networks to at least at
least give them some sort of a dose of
the truth but I haven't watched this
clip but apparently it's really good
let's listen everyone lit their hair on
fire when that phone call was a recorder
on behalf of rothensberger right it runs
an hour and change uh and and the key
line I went back and listened to her
this morning Trump says look all I want
to do is this I just want to find 11 780
votes now and he says repeatedly in my
opinion this is what we should do in my
opinion Etc if he's speaking his opinion
is there a crime in this conversation
well look I think that's what a jury is
going to decide Bill what I would say to
you is when you listen to the entire
conversation
his problem is that he clear and you
combine it with all the other
conversations he's having with Brian
Kemp um with other officials in the
legislature and
um the leaders of the legislature he was
attempting to do everything he can to
get that result and putting pressure on
that and Alan dershowitz argued last
time they were doing the same thing on
behalf of Al Gore in Florida and here we
go huge County in the year 2000 except
when Al Gore lost his legal challenges
he conceded the election
Al Gore took it all the way to the
United States Supreme Court he had
failed himself of all the legal
challenges Bill and then when the courts
were done Al Gore said I still don't
agree with it but the courts are done
I'm backing off
Donald Trump has been much different and
and I said this to the president in
December of 2020. the last time he and I
spoke
I said you have had you availed yourself
for the courts there's nothing left you
need to concede the election and he said
I will never ever ever admit it well
look if you're going to continue to use
the power of the presidency which he was
doing to put pressure on people
um you're gonna put yourself in a very
dangerous circumstance and let's put
take it aside for a second from the
criminal
we can't normalize this conduct
I mean this has never happened before in
this country ever
where you had a candidate for president
United States conduct himself in this
way to disrespect the election process
in this way to refuse to accept
the verdict of the voters and what does
it say about his judgment guys what we
know about his judgment there are two
two things I quickly want to say one
Donald Trump should probably shut his
[__] mouth when it comes to making
fat jokes about Chris Christie because
this guy's about to be processed and his
height and weight are going to be
recorded again
when he's brought through when they take
his mug shot that shit's gonna be taken
down okay so I I think that the the
weight difference the last I saw was
they're like 50 pounds different in
terms of weight who knows what Trump is
now from all this [__] stress eating
the second thing I want to point out is
Chris Christie just revealed a
conversation that he had with Trump in
December of 2022. and if you're going to
tell me that he just said that out loud
without giving that information to
someone else like I Don't Know Jack
Smith or or fonnie Willis you better
believe that he did because he just said
that in that conversation Donald Trump
would not admit that he lost that's
right
I'm sure there are more detailed privy
conversations that they had before they
broke up that now those investigations
have on the record
and and after being deposed so I'm just
gonna I just want to point that out
anyway sorry Texas ball no no and and
the first part of it when he's talking
about douchewitz and douchewitz's
opinion the guy Let Me Tell You Folks
let me give you some free wait you're
gonna make wait wait you're gonna make
Jeff mad in the chat you got to get his
name wrong
oh sorry I said yes you too Jeff I I
said December 2022 I mean December 2020
sorry yeah yeah if you go and you get a
gun right and you get together with a
bunch of guys and you plan on robbing a
bank and you go into that bank and you
hand that clerk a note and that note
says in my opinion you should hand me
all the money
you have still committed bank robbery
putting in my opinion in any of it is
not a legal defense at all and
douchewitz knows better he's just
running out there for the stupidest of
the stupids that are trying to grab on
to any bit of straw dig their nails into
any crack that they can to try to
believe this conspiracy theory that the
government is just out to get Donald
Trump because Donald Trump wants to save
them
that is [__] people that is [__]
the fact that he that one particular
line in that conversation he keeps
saying in my opinion you should do this
in my opinion you should do that that is
just like walking into a bank and saying
I have a gun and in my opinion you
should give me all the money you have
still committed bank robbery because of
all the totality of the things that you
did when you drove to the bank when you
planned your route to the bank when you
planned your route to leave the bank
there is Fannie Willis has all of that
information she has all the
communications believe me folks this
this douche which I do not know why he's
pouring gasoline on him and he called
himself a liberal Democrat this morning
[Laughter]
oh man
um salty Sylvester says Oh you mean
Trump the six five he's not six five
he's actually six two to six three and
he's not 220. he's at least 240 from
what was last recorded in Manhattan so I
wouldn't be surprised again if the
stress eating yeah and the photos we've
seen on the golf course would indicate
that it's just happier than that he's
jibs again like I said I think Donald
Trump might want to hold off and stop
the jokes uh uh or the fat jokes against
Chris Christie because he's about to go
Toe to Toe with him in this election and
considering the fact that your weight
has now been made public after being
processed for being arraigned on on
[__] Rico charges shut the [__] up
man
okay so one last before we go I wish we
had six hours today but we don't now
this is Gabe's favorite attorney
um attorney
I use that I use that term Lucy you mean
This Racist here yeah right right but
you know the best part the Chiron it
says Trump attorney reacts to latest
indictment
oh great this should be fantastic it's
17 seconds of greatness I'm sure let's
listen look at Leticia James for
instance Steve Leticia James the
Attorney General of New York stood up on
a Podium who's suing the Trump
organization and said president Trump is
an illegitimate president he is she
going to get criminally charged no what
about Hillary Clinton every day she said
you know
you can't get this kind of stupid
anywhere else man oh man what a bunch of
dumb asses so so the what about ISM and
I'm sure this is going to be the next
week and a half because all these
defendants are going to have to
surrender by next Friday I would imagine
there's going to be a handful of them
that actually don't surrender by then I
I actually I'm guessing Sydney Powell is
going to be one of them Cindy Powell is
going to make them come arrest her
because she's just that kind of
[__] whatever way they want to
take it whether they come involuntarily
or they get arrested I'm watching that
purple I'm good if they come in
handcuffs even better if they want to
surrender like little [__]
that's fine but either way they're doing
the perp walk and I'm gonna [__]
watch with Glee and eat my popcorn oh I
don't have I'll I'll make a I'll make a
cocktail I'll have some popcorn I'll be
sitting back legs up feet on the table
in Glee Joy absolute
ah just peace I want to start a gambling
pool yeah I don't really because that's
illegal in the state but I want to start
again
allegedly allegedly
18 defendants you know one is running oh
yeah one of them is running at least 19.
that's true 19 defendants yeah one of
them is going to run and I want to start
a pool so who's it going to be who do
you think is going to be the one that
Rudy Giuliani has a tendency to run away
anytime he's been served recently in the
last couple of years when it comes to
different cases he has evaded the person
that is delivering off the the oh you've
been served right see here's the
difference between being served for a
lawsuit and having an arrest warrant for
you I want to see an OJ style [__]
chase I want to see it I was on the
highway I am trying to stop these people
from getting over the Border or
illegally leaving or whatever it might
be I want to see one of them because now
live in Texas doesn't Sydney Powell live
in Texas I don't know does she does she
Texas Paul do you know is she is she she
lives in the ocean
she's not around in the political scene
down here very much well I know but I
yeah I didn't know she's a fellow Texan
or not I I thought she I thought she
lives in Texas or at least has a home in
Texas a lot of people yeah a lot of
people have addresses in Texas because
we don't have a state income tax right
they'll buy a [__] box here and rent it
and claim it as their residency and like
Elon they don't pay taxes and yeah and
then like Elon Musk you know he doesn't
pay taxes in California you know because
he lives Because He Lives I mean I'm
assuming 50 000 [__] box Shack on the
border right I'm assuming that she lives
in Texas because it that the State Bar
of Texas
sought sanctions against her including
possible disbarment yes I would imagine
that's your home state yeah I don't
imagine so anyway we're getting man I
wish we had time to talk more about the
Civil War that's going on the temple
hopes to be a civil war even though no
one showed up at this oh Tim Poole I
would love for okay look I say this as
just a joke okay bring on the Civil War
because I want to see little Captain
pool on the front lines he's got that
little musket gun and a sword in a
studio I want to see him have both of
those both hands ready charging charging
with his beanie on and saying Civil War
I would take my hat off and show Tim
Poole my awesome hair and he would go
home crying
so uh we'll continue go home crying more
coverage of 10 pool's Civil War here
tomorrow as we do every single weekday
go to realtexaspaul.com that's
realtexaspaul.com find Texas Paul there
he's gonna have a show tomorrow morning
on Wednesdays and on Saturdays it's
getting bigger and bigger over there
Gabe I know he's got some what was that
he got a brand new I supposed to play
today but we didn't ran out of time
tomorrow yeah we'll play it tomorrow
what was that on this fourth indictment
the final one this is the final
indictment no no it's not yeah no it's
not no it's not it's not gonna be the
vinyl Diamond technically it's like the
fifth because that's superseding right
and there's going to be plenty of
superseding indictments as we go along
here so uh go go check out what was that
show.com or patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez when you're over there check out
patreon.com the Tony Michaels we're
going to do some Roundtable democracy
work this week uh don't forget to check
us out on patreon also also let me check
to see if we have any venmo chats today
if you want to give us a venmo chat
during the show I'll bring you up on the
show and we'll talk about your venmo
chat I didn't get any today but maybe
we'll have some tomorrow don't forget we
got the venmo chats going and so they're
there for you guys the links down in the
description below also while you're down
there hit the Subscribe button like it
if you don't like us now you can hit the
dislike button I want to apologize again
to Jeff in the chat man I'm just making
fun but you can dislike you can give a
thumbs down for this episode if you want
or any episode where I call Jeff now he
didn't know how to spell his first name
Duncan also you can watch on Facebook at
the Tony Michaels every single weekday
and on Twitch twitch.tv slash the Tony
Michaels and don't forget the chat
continues when we stop the show the
party never stops over there on Discord
uh the link is in in the description
below but I'll put it in the chat here
for everyone if you want to go and join
the Discord this is like my God
there was like 100 people that joined
the Discord yesterday I think it was
crazy like the traffic over there is
getting nuts because the chat never ends
over there
goes on 24 7. wow what the show doesn't
go 24 7 but the chat does on Discord but
we'll be back tomorrow I promise same
time same place
Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon
[__] them
[__] em
[Music]
[__] them